so a lot of the challenges in the
automotive industry for a startup
company
is not are not necessarily technical uh
there um there is a very large barrier
you have to cross
to get accepted into the club welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
we're talking about automotives meet
dionys tesler
cto and co-founder of gardnox cyber
technologies
donnis tesla chief technology officer of
the automotive industry's first
cyber tech tier supplier guard knox is
one of the central figures propelling
israel forward in the sector in 2016
dionys merged his aviation technology
experience and his lifelong passion for
driving fast cars
into producing the cyber technology that
serves as the foundation for software
defined
and service oriented vehicles prior to
this
dionys worked as an algorithms engineer
for image processing startup transcript
which was acquired by samsung
electronics the artist holds an msc in
computer science thesis in computational
neuroscience laude
and a global mba with a focus on global
strategy from the interdisciplinary
center of herzeglia
dionys tesler welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm good thank you very much michael
it's a pleasure to be here
thank you are you calling from the
offices of guard knox right now
yes i am uh thankfully so uh we haven't
been hit
too hard by kovet in that regard so
happy to be in the office
and that's amazing and where is the
office located
uh we are actually in ramle uh
not a startup capital in israel uh but a
fun and cool place to be in
uh surrounded by a lot of cars and
trucks which is what we like
and uh less traffic so
why not i love that okay so i think
we're gonna have to start on on that
front
i don't think i've yet to to have a
startup here that is
based out of ramlet tell me a little bit
about that about this decision
you know also in the context of guard
knocks and and you know why why rumbling
um so first of all most uh
most people from tel aviv coming in to
ram they think they need a passport
um some of them have lived their entire
lives in israel
and not been to ramle so it's really
funny to hear although we're a small
country
it all started because one of our first
investors was actually the owner of
talbora group
charlie ignat and
he was kind enough to give us some space
in the tavora compound which is located
on the border between ramle and
and that has proven uh really convenient
for us
because they have a lot of
infrastructure here they have garages
they have trucks they have cars they
have
people who visit from the oems and
it's been great being here we're
actually moving to even a bigger
building right down the street
and for the foreseeable future we we
plan to stay
you know bringing the ecosystem to ramla
that's very very cool okay so now take
me back a little bit higher level
guard knox automotive cyber security
you're working on some on on some
extremely cool projects i saw whether
it's with the iron domes or with with
the air force in general
tell me a little bit about about guard
knocks and and how cyber security plays
a part in the automotive space from your
perspective
um yeah so we
the founders of guard knox myself and my
two co-founders we are
air force guys basically and uh we
worked
really on non-ip systems so a lot of
people coming in from the military are
coming in from a very
deep i.t background and that's actually
not us
we're coming from missiles airplanes
these type of things you mentioned iron
dome
and when when we came together and said
what are we good at and what can we do
together
we essentially figured that doing things
for the iet world
is not really our core value or our core
strengths
and we know more about moving things
fast moving things
real time systems and things like that
and what's applicable in the real world
and
um the idea of cars came along so i have
to say that
throughout this entire process i was the
devil's advocate i was against
all the things that we're doing today so
i was the guy saying
no to everything we are doing today in
garnok yes
because i think six years
yeah it was like i spent six years in
in like proper aviation working with
lockheed martin
uh working with the us air force
and okay so we set out to automotive and
i said that's a really tough industry
it's similar to aviation it takes years
to do something it's really hard why
should we do that
and then they went okay so let's do
cyber security because we did a lot of
it and i said but i'm tired of doing
cyber security i don't want to do any
more cyber security
and then there's like okay so let's
check if there is a market for that
in automotive and it was my task because
i was the devil's advocate to check
that so i came back and said yeah well
there is a market for that and we can
actually do something
because it's similar to the way that
we're used to in aviation
and so it began but i'm happy to say
that today
we're doing much more than cyber
security so that's also great
and second like the saving grace for me
was that i'm
i'm a car guy although i spent lots of
years in the air force and airplanes are
cool
but i think cars are way cooler so for
me working with the automotive industry
and cars was
was a big plus that's really cool
hopefully you know one day not too far
in the future the
automotive industry and the and you know
the air
traffic industry are gonna start merging
into one but i think we have a little
bit of time for that
but until then tell me a little bit
about you know as the devil's advocate
what was the process for you like as
you're
you know playing that role but at the
same time you're you realize that there
is a threshold that you need to cross
in order to convince yourself and the
rest that there is actual
potential for product market fit here
so i try to you know i try to look at it
in an objective way
and not get kind of my feelings involved
in that in that sense because the
process that we had in deciding what
we're going to do was actually
very structured so it's not like in the
movies where
we all had this eureka moment that we
should make this type of product or
another
we actually sat down made a list of
things we think are interesting and
we're good at
and and maybe new and innovative
and we started evaluating them one by
one and we actually came to this
uh idea of really building things for
the automotive industry
and um i had you know we we had to do it
face value
and i really sat down and started
researching what the automotive industry
uh is doing today today being five six
years ago
and what it seems like they need and it
was interesting to
to see that they are going through very
similar processes
as the aviation industry went through
like 15 years ago
and since i kind of saw that happening
in real time
i said that's great so we have the upper
hand here because we kind of saw what
happened there
and we can predict a little bit into the
future and that actually worked out
quite well for us because
patents we wrote like years ago and
already accepted and everything
now people in the industry are starting
to
talk about exactly these things and we
were very lucky
in that sense on the one hand but on the
other hand we did you know we did look
at it
in an analytical way we did the process
to figure that
out so that was really cool and i had to
be honest with myself and with my
co-founders
uh and not you know say ah because i
don't like it then we're not gonna do it
uh it's hard right so take me what you
have to do take me now
a little bit you know higher in the air
what is you know the space that you're
in
what are the biggest challenges that
you're that you've realized
that that now gardnox is coming to solve
so a lot of the challenges in the
automotive industry for a startup
company
is not are not necessarily technical uh
they're um there is a very large barrier
you have to cross
to get accepted into the club because
you you have to
you have to realize it's an industry
that's been kind of closed off
in itself for 50 years in some cases
there are partnerships there
uh companies that work together for a
hundred years okay
and you're trying to get into that club
as a new actor
and we are actually trying to get into
that club and disrupt
things that are not kind of in the
uh traditional sense of disruption in
the industry like autonomous driving
or things like that but really disrupt
the some of the core things in the way
that the car
operates and they're like shocked at
that they're like
who are you you you we we have people
working
more time for our company than you exist
okay
and uh that that's a huge challenge
that's a huge challenge and also being
small and
and building that trust and it was kind
of a
uh an interesting road so specifically
myself i can i can say that
i've spent about three years um
in europe mainly in germany okay
not in a relocation but 25 weeks a year
which is almost a relocation but worse
because you have to constantly travel
it's like half the year you're there
and to go door to door in in those oems
and in those tier ones and talk to
everyone who will agree to talk to us
and convince them that we know what
we're talking about that we're here to
stay
to generate trust to generate
partnerships
and then later on expand it into other
territories
which we're doing now and will continue
doing even further so
that has been i think one of the biggest
challenges
there is because it's just an industry
not built
or that in its mindset doesn't
understand
how it is to work with a new small
startup company
right so take me take me through that
journey you're a small startup and
you're going to these big
you know incumbents and you know these
huge companies that have you know
dozens of years of partnerships with
with their with their existing
you know colleagues in their in the area
and you know here along comes a new
startup that is trying to
you know change the paradigm or change
the way of thinking in one way or
another
how do you even go about building that
trust it's not like you can just you
know i guess cold email
you know 15 people and offer them to
schedule a demo right it's a little bit
more than that so how does that actually
work uh so
the the way that we chose to do it and
uh
there i'm sure that there are other ways
but we we try to find a platform
which gives us access to a significant
portion of our potential customers uh
and that platform can be an accelerator
a scalarator whatever radar there is
these days
and we were lucky enough to to kind of
meet uh both uh
really cool guys from some of the oems
who were scouting in israel and were
here to help
and on the other hand uh plug and play
which i'm sure you know
who just started a platform
in germany for the automotive industry
and signed in some of the big oems like
daimler and porsche and then others and
they created this platform because these
guys when they went
in to that accelerator they kind of
committed
to to having some resources to work with
startups
it wasn't easy but at least it provided
a platform to start a discussion
so uh we utilized our contacts
uh from from the scouts
that we were in touch with back then
there was very few by the way
and most of them were actually not local
but guys
from germany that were kind of trying to
work here
and that was an advantage because they
were
better connected into their parent
organization
and we utilized them to get us accepted
into this plug-and-play
program called startup autobahn and
from there we basically now have a
platform to to talk to some of the
people with the oems and with the tiers
and then uh the strategy was basically
to to try and build uh
initially the largest network possible
within those clients because we're
talking about companies
that are hundreds of thousands of people
okay so you have
companies such as vw group which is
upwards of six hundred thousand people
daimler upwards of
two or three hundred thousand people
it's like huge huge companies bosch is
four hundred thousand people
like you know and to try and build an
initial network to map out even the
organization
and which departments we should be
working with and once you
get that you need to develop a champion
okay within that department or
department
or somebody that you can convince
believes in you
and also has the access and the
kind of the influence to
that other people trust so you get kind
of uh
you know trust by transfer so by
proximity
to to that particular champion and
actually that
is a really cool strategy that was
uh we didn't invent it uh we were part
of an accelerator program even before
that here in israel
by ecomotion which is kind of the parent
organization for
automotive startups and it was funded by
fuel choice in the prime minister's
office
and back in the day it was in tel aviv
university and there was a guy there who
headed it ariel
seller who is now heading an accelerator
in barilan
and he is like an ex-venture guy from
the valley
and he really said guys you shouldn't be
focusing on technology
you should be focusing on building
champions
in the organizations that you want to
sell to
okay forget about the technology for now
build human relationships build trust
with your potential customers and then
then
invest in the technology so we really
utilize that
a lot of you know fake it before you
make it
type of approaches and have nice
powerpoint slides but
back then nothing behind them except
ideas cool ideas
and convince some people and then move
forward from that
and that start about one platform
basically allowed us to sign a couple of
pocs
with literally we had nothing it was
nothing
uh and uh because you know it's really
difficult to build an automotive product
or something that goes into the car
you first of all you need the actual car
you can't just build it in a generic way
so which car you're going to build it
for and that that was
the first barrier so now when we signed
off those pocs we actually
had that particular car and we could
build a product
towards that particular car based on our
technology
and that was cool because we were we
were given access to places like vaisakh
where
porsche is the main porsche r d center
we went into prototype vehicles
instrumented prototype vehicles right in
the
main porsche garage there literally
connected the wires from the main wire
harness to our unit
in in the car like it was really cool
and in daimler and mercedes
and that was the huge big jump start
like we sent
most of the company or a large portion
of the company to be in germany for a
couple of months
uh i even had the pleasure of going
around with a realtor
to get apartments to basically
rent apartments for the teams that are
coming in the various locations
um i even have funny stories about
renting apartments in germany uh
and that that is so funny because i
think one of the you know
in you know it's a little bit
counterintuitive because one of the
things that you think about you know in
a small startup the big strength that
you have is moving fast
you know creating technology that big
companies uh
or big incumbents can't because you're
moving so fast but you're saying wait
but
you have to understand the context of
the industry that you're in it's not
like you're selling another
cyber you know um product that you can
just put a schedule a demo on the
website and just take off from there
you actually need to build that trust
and i think it's really interesting to
hear that
you know from a small service
perspective in your case it actually was
building those champions that what took
you forward building that trust on a
personal level especially in these
you know companies that have maybe
hundreds of thousands of employees i
think that's really really cool
and and i i have to hear you know one of
those funny stories from
renting apartments in in germany i have
to
okay so one of the big issues in germany
is that they're really
strict on who rents the apartment and
they want to be sure
that you'll be able to pay even if you
run them for only a couple of months for
short-term rentals
and that requires like financial
statements
and things like that and obviously for
us to provide them they're
literally in hebrew or and right then
you need to translate them and then they
don't understand whether these banks
so i i hit like
i had a little bit of luck so porshi who
was one of the partners in startup
autobahn one day came along and said
we are giving you a perk like in the
porsche museum in suffenhausen you can
rent a porsche for a couple of hours
to just drive it okay and they offer it
to all the entrepreneurs in the group
to rent a porsche well basically to give
us a porsche for two hours
and uh for free well like a perk and
but you have you had like 2500 euros
collateral
and i said 25 000. i don't care give me
the porsche
right and uh apparently i was like the
only one
because all the others were afraid for
the 2500 euros
so they reserved a bunch of cars and
nobody came so they gave it to me for a
day
for like a whole day a brand new
spanking red convertible 911 gts
okay wow so i told when i figured that
i'm getting it for a day i called the
realtor
and i told her listen let's go today in
the afternoon to look at apartments
so the realtor comes along and
the owner of the house comes out and i
show up
in a brand new spanking red convertible
porsche right
no questions about financials everything
is cool
yes sir when do you need the apartment
and for how long
right and i used half of that day to go
through all the apartments we wanted to
go through
to get it and to avoid all the
contractual crap that people have been
you know like scaring me for for about a
month like all the guys in
in plug and play living in germany said
it's going to be a process and it's
difficult and that
so i basically did it all in half a day
just like coming in a porsche
i think there's way too many lessons to
be learned just from that story thank
you for sharing it with that that is
just so cool
and there are so many things that i want
to talk about but but you know
unfortunately
20 minutes are almost up and i have a
few fun questions are you ready for that
i'll give it my best shot all right
we'll start off easy and we'll get a
little bit more complicated
a favorite subject in school k-12
actually it was programming i really
liked programming i like computers
when did you start programming
uh i i didn't start before so i didn't
even have a computer at home
too early and the first one i had i
didn't really like it
so i only liked it later on due to the
fact that i started playing computer
games
the old floppy like five inch floppy
based computer games
and i only got into programming really
at school i wasn't like a computer nerd
before that
and i'm happy i i did wonderful
okay one of your role models
professionally or personally
wow there are like so so many people i
think that
uh we can go a little bit uh
towards the the cliche road people like
bill gates who is you know of course
somebody
you look at and you look at their
history and what they did but
uh i'll try something different here um
as i said i'm a car guy and i'm a fan of
motorsports
and there are a couple of race drivers
which i really look at and i think that
they're
amazing people people like lewis
hamilton who is the current f1 champion
who
literally came from a tough neighborhood
uh
in the uk with with a really rough
background
into a sport that it's probably one of
the most expensive sports in the world
and became a seven-time world champion
in line with michael schumacher
but coming from nothing which is almost
unheard of
or people like walter roll
who is a driver that beat audi in a
rally
when audi was considered unbeatable in a
car which was considered
to be supposed to fall apart after one
race
like you know these these type of things
like the mindset that these guys
have and for me doing it kind of on an
enthusiast level
is absolutely amazing it's like a race
driver mindset is
absolutely amazing i love that okay
and three ques three words that you
would use to describe yourself
um adventurous risk taking
let's say it's one word and
but analytical or calculated
okay adventurous risk taker but
analytical and calculative i love that
the honest thank you very very much
best of luck with the company best of
luck with with everything you're doing
and
keep taking those those amazing stories
they need to be shared
it's very very cool and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you youtube it was a pleasure